Isabelle Barroso n'imagine pas cuisiner
autrement qu'avec une flamme c'est
beaucoup plus agréable c'est beaucoup
plus rapide aussi mais ces habitudes
vont peut-être devoir changer Montréal
entre les mains un rapport très clair
sur le sort qu'elle doit réserver au gaz
on recommande entre autres d'interdire
dans les plus brefs délais que tout
nouveau bâtiment sur le territoire de la
ville soit raccordé à un réseau de
distribution de gaz naturel mais cela ne
concernerait pas seulement le mode de
chauffage la commission municipale qui
fait ses recommandations voudrait aussi
proscrire dans les plus brefs délais
l'installation de nouveaux appareils
fixes intérieur incluant les cuisinières
à gaz une proposition qui va au-delà de
la feuille de route proposée par la
ville l'année dernière lors du sommet
climat qu'on n'était pas allé aussi loin
depuis ce temps là ça a été beaucoup
dans l'actualité les cuisinières au gaz
donc c'est sûr qu'on va le considérer
c'est sûr que si on veut installer
demain un appareil au gaz on est mieux
d'y réfléchir même si la réglementation
n'est pas encore en vigueur une
trentaine de mémoire avait été déposées
lors de la consultation publique dont
celui de Greenpeace c'est un geste très
fort d'avoir un rapport si clair de la
part d'élus qui démontre le leadership
de Montréal autant au niveau de la lutte
climatique que la santé de la population
mais aussi en lumière que le
gouvernement du Québec dort au gaz sur
cette problématique là alors qu'il
devrait lui aussi légiférer du côté des
propriétaires d'immeubles commerciaux on
attend des incitatifs et des détails
on indique que Québec notamment de
fournir l'énergie pour faire la
transformation vous et moi aussi qu'à
Québec en ce moment on cherche l'énergie
l'énergie qui mise sur le gaz naturel
renouvelable estime que Montréal se
priverait de solutions zéro émission si
elle choisissait d'interdire des types
d'appareils comme les cuisinières ou les
foyers mais la ville se donne jusqu'à
fin avril pour proposer son règlement
ici Mathieu pros Radio-Canada Montréal